GILBERT STRONG: Well, you
see spring has finally
come to Boston.
My sweater is gone and it's
April the 16th, I think.
It's getting late spring.
So today, this video is the
nice case, constant coefficient,
linear equations, and the right
hand side is an exponential.
Those are the best.
And we've seen that before.
In fact, let me extend, we saw
it for first order equations,
here it is for second
order equations,
and it could be an
nth order equation.
We could have the nth derivative
and all lower derivatives.
The first derivative,
the function itself,
0-th derivative
with coefficients,
constant coefficients,
equalling e
to the st. That's
what makes it easy.
And what do we do when the
right hand side is e to the st?
We look for a
solution, a multiple
of e to the st.
Capital Y times e
to the st, that's going to work.
We just plug into the equation
to find that transfer function
capital Y. Can I just do that?
I'll do it for the nth degree.
Why not?
So will I plug this in for y,
every derivative brings an s.
Capital Y is still
there, the exponential
is going to be still
there, and then
there are all the s's that
come down from the derivatives,
and s's from the nth derivative.
One s from the first derivative,
no s from the constant term.
Do you see that
equation is exactly
like what we had before with
as squared plus Bs plus C.
We have quadratic equation,
the most important case.
Now, I'm including that with
any degree equation, nth degree
equation.
And what's the solution for Y?
Because e to the st
cancels e to the st.
That whole thing equals 1.
I divide by this
and I get Y equal 1
over that key polynomial.
It's a nth degree polynomial.
And the 1 over it is called
the transfer function.
And that transfer function
transfers the input--
e to the st-- to the
output-- Ye to the st.
It gives the
exponential response.
Very nice formula.
Couldn't be better.
And you remember for
second degree equations,
our most important case is
as squared Bs plus C. That's
the solution almost every time.
But one thing can go wrong.
One thing can go wrong.
Suppose for the particular
s, the particular exponent,
in the forcing function, suppose
that s in the forcing function
is also one of the s's
in the no solutions.
You remember the no solutions,
there are two s's-- s1 and s2--
that make this 0,
that make that 0.
Those are the s1 and s2 that
go into the no solutions.
Now, if the forcing s is one
of those no solution s's, we
have a problem.
Because this is 1 over 0 and
we haven't got an answer yet.
1 over 0 has no meaning.
So I have to, this
is called resonance.
Resonance is when
the forcing exponent
is one of the no exponents
that make this 0.
And there are two of those
for second order equations
and there will be n different
s's-- s1, s2, up to sn--
for nth degree equations.
Those special s's, I
could also call them
poles of the transfer function.
The transfer function has
this in the denominator
and when this is 0,
that identifies a pole.
So the s1, s2, to
sn are the poles
and we hope that this s is not
one of those, but it could be.
And if it is, we
need a new formula.
So that's the only
remaining case.
This is a completely
nice picture.
We just need this last
case with some resonance
when s equals say s1.
I'll just pick s1 and
when A, I know that As 1
squared plus Bs 1 plus C is 0.
So Y would be 1 over 0.
And we can't live with that.
I've written here for the
second degree equation
same possibility
for the nth degree,
An s1 to the nth
plus A0 equals 0.
That would be a
problem of resonance.
In the nth degree equation, this
gives us resonance, you see,
because remember, the no
solutions were e to the s1t
was a no solution.
If I plug-in e to the s1t,
the left side will give 0.
So I can't get for equal to a
forcing term on the right side.
I need a new solution.
I need a new y of t.
Can I tell you what it is?
It's a typical case of
L'Hopital's rule from calculus
when we approach
this bad situation,
and we are getting a 1 over 0.
Well, you'll see a 0 over 0
and that's L'Hopital's aim for.
So where do we start?
A Y particular
solution is this e
to the st over this As
squared plus Bs plus C. Right.
That's our particular solution.
If it works.
Resonance is the case when this
doesn't work because that's 0.
Now, that's a
particular solution.
I'll subtract off a no solution.
I could do that.
I still have a solution.
So I subtract off e to the s1t.
So S1 is, e to the
s1t is a no solution.
This is what I would call
a very particular solution.
It's very particular because
a t equals 0, it's 0.
Do you see that, you see
what's happening here.
The question, resonance
happens when s approaches s1.
Resonance is s
equal to, resonance
itself is at the thing.
Now, we let s sneak
up on s1 and we ask
what happens to that formula.
You see, we're sneaking
up on resonance.
At resonance, when s
equals s1, that will be 0
and that will be 0.
That's our problem.
So approach it and you
end up with the derivative
of this divided by the
derivative of this.
Do you remember L'Hopital?
It was a crazy rule in calculus,
but here it's actually needed.
So as s goes to s1
this goes to 0 over 0,
so I have to take
derivative over derivative.
So let me write the answer.
Y resonant.
Can I call this the resonant
solution when s equals s1.
And what does it equal?
Well, I take the s
derivative of this
and divide it by the
s derivative of that.
Derivative over derivative.
The s derivative of
that is te to the st.
And the s derivative
of this is 2As plus B.
And now, I have derivative
over derivative,
I can let s go to s1.
So s goes to s1, this goes
to s1, and I get an answer.
The right answer.
This is the correct
solution and you notice
everybody spots this t factor.
That t factor is a
signal to everyone
that we're in a
special case when
two things happen to be equal.
Here the two things
are the s and the s1.
So that will work.
So do you see the
general picture?
It's always this te
to the st, t above.
And down below we have the
derivative of this polynomial
at s equal s1.
You know it's theoretically
possible that we
could have double resonance.
We would have double
resonance if that thing is 0.
If s1 was a double root, if
s1 was a double root, then,
well, that's just absurd,
but it could happen.
Then not only is that
denominator 0, but after one
use of L'Hopital, so we
have to drag L'Hopital back
from the hospital
and say do it again.
So we would have a
second derivative.
I won't write down that solution
because it's pretty rare.
So what has this video done?
Simply put on record
the simplest case
possible with a forcing
function, e to the st.
And above all, we've identified
this transfer function.
And let me just anticipate that
if we need another way to solve
these equations, instead
of in the t domain,
we could go to the Laplace
transform in the s domain.
We could solve it
in the s domain.
And this is exactly
what we'll meet when
we take the Laplace transform.
That will be the
Laplace transform,
which we have to deal with.
So that transfer function
is a fundamental,
this polynomial tells us, its
roots tell us the frequencies,
s1, s2, and the no solutions.
And then 1 over that tells
us the right multiplier
in the force solution.
So constant coefficients,
exponential forcing,
the best case possible.
Thank you.